jacques yves cousteau est mort mercredi
à paris l'été dans sa 88e année cet
homme maître par le matériel et par
l'image de l'exploration des océans fait
figure de héros pour les français c'est
aussi une star à l'étranger le
commandant avait également su avec plus
ou moins de réussite bâtir un empire
contesté par certains scientifiques mais
académiciens mais palme d'or à cannes en
1956 pour le monde du silence dans l'
aventure cousteau il y à la calypso ou
jojo le mérou cousteau disait le
plongeur s'ils cessent de nager reste
entre deux eaux comme un archange
invités de ce journal madame cousteau et
le docteur jean louis etienne parmi les
autres titres de l'actualité collision
dans l'espace entre la station orbitale
mir et le vaisseau de ravitaillement
l'équipage est sauf le possible report
du procès papon pour raisons budgétaires
enfin la réforme aubry sur les
licenciements le ministre de l'emploi et
de la solidarité veut plus de sécurité
juridique et moins de précarité pour les
salariés
madame monsieur bonsoir un destin au
coin de la route
à sa sortie de l'école navale dans le
milieu des années trente cousteau pense
à une carrière dans l'aviation
mais il un accident de voiture et sa
rééducation passe par la natation de la
l'épopée qui va suivre
josé dans la pierre
dans le monde des ténèbres cousteau
apporte la lumière plus avec une caméra
bricoler de ses mains le cinéaste fait
de la vie sous-marine une star de
l'écran le public et son chat canet
hollywood est celle l'exploit le monde
du silence reçoit palme d'or et au ce
cas on est en 1956 ainsi comment sa
carrière médiatique de l'homme préféré
des français
des gens rédigent leurs souvenirs en
prenant des notes ont vécu dans leur
journal
moi je tenais mon journal j'ai toujours
tenu un journal avec une caméra
né en 1910 à saint-andré-de-cubzac
jacques-yves découvre la plongée dans un
camp de vacances du vermont à 13 ans il
s'achète une caméra avec son argent de
poche à 16
il joue à l'acteur dans ses films
d'amateurs sortie deuxième de l'école
navale de brest cousteau s'engage sur la
jeanne d'arc boucle un tour du monde
épouse simone melchior en 1937 mais sous
la tenue militaire bouillonne
l'ingénieur inventeur hanté par
l'exploration sous-marine en 1943 le
jeune officier met au point le
scaphandre autonome pour la première
fois le plongeur est libre de ses
mouvements
l'homme grenouille est née cousteau part
en croisade pour sauver la méditerranée
j'étais bourré de boissons la vie était
intense là la flore était intense
également sollicité cordes qui ont
complètement disparu des mérous il a pu
et les poissons de passage y en a très
peu aujourd'hui la question est très
grave
l allure méditerranée lie aux caraïbes
et cetera notre organisation se battra
aux points chauds où qu'ils soient dans
le monde entier pour mener à bien son
combat
l'inventeur continue sur sa lancée il
réalise lui-même son idée de soucoupe
plongeante et 350 m de fond sont à la
portée de son objectif
puis c'est vibre sous la mer qui le
tente le pionnier de la plongée imagine
ces maisons sous-marines où il passe
plusieurs semaines par 100 mètres de
fond
auparavant le pacha des maires s'étaient
offert la calypso dans ses 40 ans le
tournant de sa carrière
en présence de la princesse grâce le
départ du navire explorateurs s'effectue
face au musée océanographique que
cousteau va diriger pendant 30 ans
à bord de cet ancien navire de guerre
russe tout en main' scientifique
plongeurs et ses inséparables caméra les
missions se succèdent d'une mer à
l'autre recherche d'épaves études
géologiques
à chaque retour et kilomètres de
pellicule on m'avait prévenu que faire
marcher un bateau super 8 ça a été en
fait mon premier problème sérieux les
premières années simone et moi nous
étions obligés d'emprunter ou même
devant d'envoi pas tout ce que nous
avions les difficultés commencent dans
les années 60 le gouvernement français
ce gel ces subventions
l'explorateur se tourner vers les états
unis
le succès est immédiat plus de trois
cent mille américains adhère à la
fondation cousteau sa série télévisée
dépasse audience de dallas c'est à new
york que le captain planet bien fêter
ses 85 ans à bord de l'alcyone son
nouveau bateau futuriste propulsé par
deux turbos voile en 1979 cousteau subi
le drame de sa vie la perte de son fils
préféré désormais c'est pour les
générations futures qu'il va continuer
de se battre avec les enfants a
peut-être parce qu'ils n'ont pas été
atteints par un l'expérience de la vie
la plupart des adultes ont perdu leur
spontanéité cousteau sauve l'antarctique
de l'exploitation minière condamne les
essais nucléaires
alerte sur un nouveau tchernobyl mais
pour le prophète de l'environnement la
surpopulation est le premier problème de
la planète
à 79 ans cousteau entre à l'académie
française
parmi les immortels j'ai contemplé
l'étrange hippocampe dragon j'ai souri
aux aspects de son camouflage et j'ai
remercié dieu d'avoir eu tant
d'imagination
oh
tant d'imagination de greenpeace à tout
le monde politique français de
washington à stockholm de la société
royale britannique géographique à vaclav
havel le président de la république
tchèque
l'hommage se veut unanime on salue
l'océanographe celui qui a cherché à
protéger l'environnement pour les
générations futures
jacques yves cousteau est mort mercredi
matin son domicile parisien d'un
accident cardiaque sur place agnès
vahramian vincent de guyenne sa famille
la veillée une partie de la nuit
le commandant cousteau cet état à 2h30
ce matin alors qu'il était en
convalescence chez lui suite à une
affection respiratoire
il était malade depuis trois mois toute
la journée dans l'immeuble de sa
fondation à paris
l'équipe cousteau a reçu des messages de
sympathie et fait patienter des
journalistes venus du monde entier les
plus émues sans doute les chef
d'expédition des fidèles depuis quinze
ou vingt ans et qui entoureront lors de
sa conférence de presse
la seconde épouse du commandant le
commandant cousteau a rejoint le monde
du silence
mais sa voix va continuer à se faire
entendre défendre l'héritage reprendre
le flambeau
tous avaient surtout envie ce soir
d'évoquer celui qu'ils admirent temps je
me suis une année d'une anecdote par
exemple ou un marin c'était décès ou le
commandant a pensé le doigt du marin et
deux minutes après il était au téléphone
avec le président des états unis
c'était ça le commandant cousteau est ce
que vous avez un souvenir qui vous
revient aujourd'hui aux parties de
scrabble
on a fait tous les deux acharnés qu'un
bon moment parce que c'était quelqu'un
qu'on écoutait beaucoup
oui le fils du commandant a été le
premier ce matin à rendre hommage à son
père
ils s'étaient fâchées pendant plusieurs
années j'ai vu il ya trois semaines on a
eu l'occasion de se parler
bien que c'était très difficile pour lui
en tous les cas j'ai pu communiquer tout
tout le monde amour pour lui et lui lui
garantir que je fais tout ce que je
trouve pour être à sa hauteur
les obsèques de jacques yves cousteau
auront lieu lundi à paris
madame rousseau merci d'avoir accepté
malgré votre deuil
notre invitation hommage unanime nous
l'avons dit tout à l'heure
quelle est la première pensée que vous
avez qu est la première évocation de
votre mari vous souhaitez nous donner ce
soir je suis sensible à l'hommage parce
qu'ils le méritent et le mérite l'homme
le mérite son oeuvre le mérite et je
remercie le public est le monde entier
de ce qu'ils offrent aujourd'hui je veux
dire que un hommage ce n'est pas pour
lui un arrêt sur images le produit
commandant va continuer le commandant
n'a pas tout dit le commandant encore
beaucoup de choses à nous apprendre
on y reviendra tout à l'heure dans la
suite de ce journal mais j'aimerais vous
demandez vous qui avez eu deux enfants
un garçon et une fille avec le
commandant cousteau
comment est-ce qu'on peut partager la
vie d'un homme qui les trois quarts du
temps court le monde si ce n'est pas les
neuf dixièmes du temps côté veut
nettement si j'étais là ce soir parce
que je suis sa femme je serai pas ma
place là-bas sera prêt mais elle serait
un premier enfant
et croyez bien que si je suis là c'est
parce que je pense qu'il m'a donné une
autre mission justement qui est bien
celle de comprendre ce qu'il a fait et
de le continuer est-ce qu'on peut
commenter les images que l'on voit sur
sur l'écran c'est une septième est un
moment d'anniversaire c'est un bon
anniversaire sur une plage au crépuscule
avec les enfants
nous avons fait une grande surprise nous
avons bâti pendant une journée entière
un immense gâteau de sable et ses dires
le symbole et en tue place telle qu'elle
me voyait de la façon qu'ils font
peut-être pas sans quelque chose s qui
excuse et de quantité dans la famille
avec avec ses enfants et avec goût et ce
qui était ce qu'il racontait son
aventure où est ce que est ce qu'il
pensait plutôt à la famille du
commandant cet homme poète c'est un
musicien c'est aussi merveilleux père de
famille et je crois que quand il est en
famille pensées à la famille alors on
reviendra tout à l'heure sur sur le
combat qu'ils ont entamée sur sur les
suites de ce combat je voulais
simplement signaler que mardi sortira en
librairie le dernier livre de votre mari
réalisé en collaboration avec susanne
wille funk bein l'homme la pieuvre et
l'orchidée fidèle à son combat dans ce
texte qui est bâti sur des notes prises
pendant vingt ans il dénonce à nouveau
la destruction des réserves de poissons
le saccage de la faune et de la flore
marine ou encore le tout nucléaire qu'il
soit civil militaire
c'est pendant l'occupation que
jacques-yves cousteau commence donc ses
premières expérimentations de plongée
sous marine
c'est également en 42 ans 45 que deux
courts métrages sont tirés de ses
premières explorations
cette association de la mer et de
l'image culminera avec en 1956 avec la
complicité de louis malle une palme d'or
à cannes pour le monde du silence dont
voici quelques extraits et une guest
star
jojo le mérou
cette fois ça y est il est devenu notre
ami et plongèrent l'ont baptisé jojo
jojo le mérou m'accorderez vous cette
valse
oui
ne nous quittent plus les plongeurs font
leur talent et de décompression jojo
vient leur tenir compagnie
notre nouvelle monture a malheureusement
besoin de respirer
c'est jour de fête chez les dauphins ils
sont venus par centaines
nous n'en avons jamais temps
jacques yves cousteau et le français
dont la cote de popularité a toujours
été invariablement au beau fixe
aux états unis on dit une star jean
louis goût si toute la journée l'annoncé
de la mort du commandant cousteau et
l'accident de la station spatiale mir se
sont partagés l'ouverture des journaux
télévisés américains
ici on l'appelait de flammes ce captain
pour beaucoup il était le seul français
qu'il connaissait et le vice président
américain al gore qu'il avait rencontré
plusieurs fois lui a rendu un hommage
appuyé
c'était un géant dans tous les sens du
terme est d'ailleurs un avis personnel
on a eu l'occasion de travailler
ensemble je suis pas pris avec lui
c'était un héros pour tous les hommes
les femmes et les enfants du monde
entier
aux etats unis plus qu'ailleurs il était
une sorte de mythe
ces rencontres avec les présidents
américains ses livres ses émissions de
télévision ces documentaires évidemment
sont resté dans toutes les mémoires
je me rappelle des liés à la télévision
quand j'étais petite ma vie dans les
océans
je pense que les océans n'ont jamais eu
de meilleur ambassadeur que cousteau en
1974 il avait fondé la cousteau society
et pour les océanographes les chercheurs
les plongeurs américains
il devient et reste un exemple c'était
un géant
non seulement il a montré aux américains
que l'océan n'était pas une poubelle
dans laquelle on pouvait tout jeter mais
grâce à lui des lobbys se sont créés et
certaines lois aujourd'hui sont inspirés
de son action ce soir la plupart des
grandes chaînes de télévision
américaines vont faire des émissions
spéciales sur le commandant cousteau en
fait pays où l'impact des médias est
très important et le plus bel hommage
que puisse lui rendre les américains
c'est le brevet du poumon aquatique qui
a commencé de rendre couche-tôt riches
qui allait lui permettre d'aller au bout
de sa volonté d'exploration avec émile
gagnant il mettra au point des 46 le
scaphandre autonome
ce n'était que le début d'une longue
série de curiosité et de trouvailles
josé blond la pierre
dès le début c'est l'obsession du
commandant cousteau
comment pénétrer sous l'eau et s'y
mouvoir en toute liberté sans les
fameuses caf en dhr avec quelques amis
il invente alors le masque et son tuba
c'est ce qui va lui donner les clés
d'accès à ce monde du silence les clés
de la réussite aussi
gusto fait alors ses premières photos et
ses premières rencontres avec le monde
sous marin
mais ces rencontres sont trop brève
il lui faut trop souvent faire surface
pour respirer
l'idée géniale c'est l'ingénieur gagnant
qu'il aura avec son fameux détendeur
pour les voitures à gazogène on est
alors en pleine occupation gusto et
gagnant l'adapt à des bouteilles
d'oxygène
le premier homme grenouille est né il
s'appelle cousteau sont eux lance était
de glaner des renseignements à droite et
à gauche et de faire une synthèse pour
assembler tout ça et dire on va faire
ceci et ça va marcher et plus parler
d'eux j'ai tendance à marcher et sa
première caméra sous marine va marcher
elle aussi
cousteau va faire découvrir au monde
entier ce qu'il n'avait jamais vue et
pour descendre plus bas
toujours plus profond et toujours plus
longtemps l'inventeur met au point un
nouveau mélange gazeux et comme ça ne
suffit plus ce seront les premiers
bathyscaphe et même les maisons sous la
mer deux hommes peuvent vivre 21 jours
par 100 mètres de fond et puis il y à
l'autre rêve du commandant cousteau
faire en sorte que les cargos ne vaut
lui pas la mer et soit uniquement
propulsé par le vent c'est son fameux
alcyone une ambition pour les navires du
monde entier resté à l'état de prototype
avant les lionnes il y avait eu la
calypso et c'est autour de ce bateau que
se sont regroupés aujourd'hui à
marseille tous les admirateurs du
commandant cousteau qui sont venus voir
ce bateau donc qui avait été acheté par
le commandant 1950 à malte et qui avait
coulé le l'an dernier à singapour
le commandant avait monté une dernière
expédition pour fidèles retrouver ce
bateau qui avait accompagné une grande
partie de ses expéditions la calypso
aujourd'hui à marseille donc avec cet
hommage des marseillais près de la
calypso en direct avec nous de marseille
nous allons retrouver le chef plongeur
de l'équipe cousteau claude clos de way
sli claude où l'entendait oui je vous
reçois reichert alors oui je vous
entends est ce que est ce qu'on peut
parler de la vie à bord de ce bateau
alors d'abord on peut peut-être dire que
vous êtes vous étiez chef plongeur et où
vous appeler si j'ai bien relu mes notes
les mousquemers pourquoi les mousses que
mais pardon de d'abord on appelait pas
les mousses comme lé mousquemers sur
l'identité du commandant cousteau du
comment l'on taille aise et de frédéric
dumas ça c'est effectivement leur
identité moi j'ai eu le privilège a
certainement d'y être sûr qu'il souhaite
nommer tête chef robert ont commandé des
maisons sous la mer d'après continent 2
je crois qu'il pourra mettre quelque
chose en place surtout un tel moment
alors je n'ai alors les civilistes mère
alors les souvenirs souvenirs
mais à mes souvenirs monsieur
c'est que vous pensez bien
qu'aujourd'hui je suis plein d'émotions
de chagrin au nom de mes camarades car
j'aimerais qu'ils soient tous à mes
côtés mais je crois qu'aujourd'hui s'il
y avait je dirais un seul mot à dire
je crois que le monde de la mer le on
n'est pas facile même temps de la mère
ou le voit sur ces images il n'est pas
facile mais il est aussi l'image que
donnait le commandant cousteau dans son
oeuvre mondiales sur la protection de
l'environnement et je crois
qu'aujourd'hui que nous sommes tous
effectivement peiné et s'éteint
pardonnez moi mon émotion mais c'était
beaucoup de chagrin que je me trouve ce
soir devant l'étrave de notre célèbre
navire
voilà je dirais tous vraiment à tous
ceux qui l'ont connu rendant hommage à
un grand homme et je me permets de dire
à à toute la famille et à madame
cousteau en particulier clownesque
qu'est ce que vous retenez votre
aventure avec coustous est-ce que c'est
l'esprit d'équipé ou est-ce que celle
aventure c'est l'esprit d'équipé
laventure l'été par du tout ce que nous
avons vécu mais je crois que derrière
tout ça c'est l'oeuvre d'un homme qui a
su mettre en place une organisation
extraordinaire avec cette équipe
merveilleuse dont nous nous sommes tous
fiers aujourd'hui de faire partie de cet
historique
quel était le caractère du commandant à
bord de son bateau est-ce que c'était
quelqu'un qui avait des coups de gueule
comme tous les marins qui se respecte on
les coups de gueule des marins dans les
conditions difficiles on peut pas
précéder coup de gueule c'était un homme
de décision
c'était c'était un homme qui savait
effectivement un certainement qu'on lit
dans la marine je prends je crois
qu'effectivement comme il est il est
d'un maul il était d'azam houle était la
royale et que à certains moments où
c'est très bien que c'était sa décision
cris primés merci claude the way sli de
ce témoignage jean louis etienne docteur
jean louis etienne qui et quel regard
portez vous sur votre nez vous êtes vous
aussi un homme de l'extrême et de
l'exploration
on a circonstances l'épaule qui quel
regard portez-vous sur cousteau à ce qui
me concerne c'est un formidable
pionniers c'est un metteur en scène de
la mer fabuleux c'est un homme qui a été
capable de tenir longtemps avec un
bateau
avec une équipe avec des plongeurs
avec une production cinématographique
toujours avec cette idée de montrer la
mère de montrer la terre et pour être un
petit élève par rapport à tout ce qu'il
a fait je peux réaliser moi la tâche que
représente le travail qu'a fait cet
homme l'énergie qu'il a dû déployer
pendant très longtemps pour tenir parce
que il a évoqué un petit peu dans au
tout début en disant j'ai acheté un
bateau et qu'on m'a dit que ça allait
être difficile
mené cette existence est resté libre
mais il l'a été ça c'est une
c'est une grande oeuvre question vous
souhaitez quand même quelqu'un qui
n'avait pas forcément l'image toujours
positif chez les scientifiques comment
expliquez vous cette cette distance que
les scientifiques mettaient entre entre
cousteau et si vous voulez chaque
scientifique et est vraiment très
pointue dans son travail dans son métier
qu'on est parfaitement son univers est
alors que le commandant cousteau et
nombre de synthèse il n'a pas voulu
faire dans chacun des domaines qu'il a
abordé une oeuvre de pointe une
recherche de pointe sur l'objectif caché
un touche à tout de génie
c'était un grand metteur en scène de la
vie de la nature donc en touche à tout
de génie c'était un homme de synthèse
dans une réunion quand il y avait
plusieurs avis qui s'exprimait il avait
cette aptitude à dire tac tac tac ont
fait ça la dir ouest et tout d'un coup
le flux se met en route et ça c'est la
force et sa force à lui il a su tenir
parce que cette oeuvre est colossal et
c'est un gros boulot pour faire ça
jacques yves cousteau avait la passion
de la découverte le don de l'image et
aussi avec plus ou moins de succès le
sens des affaires
l' empire couche tôt bertrand cocq
daniel wolfromm
premier grand revers dans la vie de
jacques yves cousteau hommes d'affaires
la faille du parc c'est annick ouverts
en 1989 aux halles à paris il devait
accueillir un million de visiteurs par
an le public n'a jamais suivi résultat
la fermeture en 92 et une ardoise de 120
millions de francs c'est un leader
c'était un trou financier sont jeunes
beaux extraordinaire c'était un échec
mais je dire toute la vie comporte ses
succès et ses échecs ses succès eux
étaient les plus nombreux à commencer
par son premier gros coup c'était il ya
cinquante ans de véritables pièces de
musée aujourd'hui ces équipements de
plongeurs autonomes l'homme
enfin livre sous la mer les brevets de
ces matériels rapporteront des royalties
considérable à jacques yves cousteau cet
argent avec celui de généreux mécènes
lui permettra de financer toutes ces
expéditions dans les premières années
des épopées films et des centaines de
reportages pour la télévision le plus
souvent financées par les chaînes
américaines
à l'image de cnn aujourd'hui encore
distributeur exclusif aux états unis des
oeuvres de cousteau fils il ya le nom du
commandant cousteau
à lui seul il suffisait pour signer un
contrat son nom un véritable label qu'il
savait promouvoir comme ici entouré de
stars lors de ces grands shows qu'il
affectionnait tant pour faire passer ses
messages
l' empire cousteau survivra-t-il à la
disparition du patriarche ces dernières
années une brouille avec son fils
jean-michel sur l'utilisation de leur
nom à des fins commerciales avaient déjà
révélé les difficultés qu'il y aurait à
succéder aux grands hommes tant qu en
octobre jean louis etienne quand vous
voyez ces errances d'une certaine
manière de deux couches tout vous avez
vous avez un commentaire
certains ont aussi accusé parfois de
jouer enfin son équipe en tout cas de
jouer un peu trop avec les poissons
notamment avec les requins
non tout ça sont des détails ce sont des
détails si on veut vraiment un certain
moment donné prendre à la loupe
l'existence de normes n'arrive toujours
à trouver certaines failles on peut les
creuser on peut aller très loin
87 ans bientôt 88 c'est une langue et
d'islande
quelle fidélité à son oeuvre je pense
que de temps en temps on peut trouver
quelques failles dans la vie d'un homme
mais retenons son oeuvre si on veut
s'acharner sur le coeur on peut toujours
y arriver c'est très récent tout ça tous
sont passés colossal regardez cet
hommage qu'on fait à cet homme partout
dans le monde
souvent c'est difficile d'être prophète
en son pays je crois que regardons son
oeuvre elle est colossal et elle va
durer malgré ici ou là quelques quelques
errances que je vis une seconde couche
tôt se voulait donc encore combattants
jusque dans sa 88e année notamment pour
l'environnement contre le nucléaire
il appelait le surgénérateur superphénix
sous phoenix il s'insurgeait contre la
reprise des essais nucléaires décidée
par le président chirac
ces derniers combats patrice pollet
les essais nucléaires français le site
de murs euros dans les années 70 costaud
commencent à s'intéresser aux possibles
retombées de la radioactivité sur
l'environnement
le commissariat à l'énergie atomique
l'invite sur place pendant plusieurs
semaines sur et sous la tle ils
procèdent à des relevés
sa conclusion d'alors est que mur roi ne
présente aucune forme de radioactivité
une phrase sur laquelle il ne reviendra
jamais pour jacques yves cousteau
l'écologie d'un problème planétaire
il sait quel antarctique est convoité
pour ses richesses il se rend sur place
pour que ce continent couvert de glace
reste le sanctuaire de la nature or la
mer est menacée je le sais bien
la pollution augmente le littoral se
couvre de béton et des femmes associées
au mouvement écologiste pour ces
élections
1981 le commandant cousteau franchi une
nouvelle étape
ils s'engagent politiquement
présidentielle mais certains lui
reprochent le mélange des genres alors
il renonce à la politique n'est pas à
l'écologie et se prononce contre la
reprise des essais nucléaires
une scène qui ne s'invente pas cousteau
se bat alors contre le béton le pont de
l'île de ré ne lui plaît pas il n'aura
pas gain de cause
mais ce commandant obstiné ne baisse
jamais les bras
1992 le voilà à l'est à kozlodoui la
centrale nucléaire bulgare à un problème
de taille la cuve du réacteur numéro 1
est fissurée cousteau inspectent se fait
expliquer la situation
c'est de retour à paris sa conclusion
est formel la réalité c'est qu'il faut
fermer
causse le dui le danger du nucléaire sa
dernière grande bataille dans une vie en
forme de combat au sommet de riom 92
jacques yves cousteau avait lancé une
pétition pour les générations futures ce
qui lui avait valu le surnom de captain
planet
comment les enfants reçoivent t-il
couche tôt aujourd'hui patricia charnolé
nathalie gallet enfin tu connais le
commandant plus tôt
et un autre à la route est ok
parce que c'est bon le monde du silence
est aussi celui des enfants pour eux le
commandant cousteau
c'est l'amie des animaux et
l'explorateur courrier
au moins ça nous en a un ça va
omar ben laden soissons coustous c'est
aussi l'espoir de l' aventure ça t'a
donné l envie d'y aller aussi d'aller où
la fille ma mère j'aimerais avoir la
même vie que lui
tu
penda ville quand tu rentres plein de
fois sont à jamais
en direct avec nous de marseille
dominique serafini dominique que
serafini vous êtes le dessinateur enfin
vous avez été ces dernières années le
dessinateur des bandes dessinées qui
illustrait laventure cousteau comment
l'avez vous rencontrée au d'une façon
assez extraordinaire parce que c'est pas
partie des de la génération des
pionniers de la calypso
j'avais 15 ans lorsque le monde du
silence est apparu sur les écrans vers
le mac robes et les écrans et ça m'a
absolument bouleversés et donc comme
j'étais dessinateur je suis
allez voir le coût soit la fin d'une
conférence pour lui proposer de mettre
en bande dessinée le monde du silence
j'avais 15 ans n'était pas très près et
j que très gentiment mais nous verrons
ça plus tard l'enfer le projet a été
réalisé et 20 ans plus tard comment
est-ce que comment est ce que vous
travaillez avec lui vous voyez ils vous
ont parlé où vous travaillez uniquement
sur sur le film a justement le tout le
plaisir du travail je réalisais avec le
commandant cousteau c'est que j'ai pu
aller sur calypso à plusieurs reprises
parce que il voulait absolument que je
puisse reconstituer l'ambiance de la vie
à bord
je ne sais pas pour moi du tout de
copier les signes ou des photos merci de
ce témoignage
madame coustous ont parlé de l'avenir
tout à l'heure et peut-être sur l'idée
de l'avenir à rio cousteau dit défendant
les générations futures on s'aperçoit
aujourd'hui à new york pour un même
somme et d'environnement que de ce point
de vue c'est plutôt un échec les les
pays ont du mal à protéger leur
environnement
comment est ce que vous comptez
pérenniser laventure couche tôt et son
combat je suis depuis plusieurs années
la collaboratrice et commandants et je
sens qu'avec le livre qu'elle nous
laisse qui est un testament que nous
allons pouvoir qui va être notre guide
nous allons pouvoir mener à bien
plusieurs de ces projets qui sont projet
calypso 2 qui sera la vigie de la
planète et qui est un superbe sujet pour
les générations qui viennent avec la
voix humaine qui est une
chaînes de télévision qui permettront
aux cultures qui risque de se perdre de
s'exprimer de se faire connaître
là aussi je crois que c'est une façon de
participer à l'écriture
l'éclosion la télévision les droits des
générations futures ou venu d'en parler
ils ne sont pas encore signé mais ils
sont en route ils ont été approuvés au
comité exécutif de l'unesco ils sont en
route pour une signature d'ici la fin de
l'année
c'est un peu plus long que prévu mais ça
vient et je crois que le commandant nous
laisse beaucoup de cadeaux pour les
générations qui viennent et il m'a
demandé de l'aider à l'est à les mettre
en valeur et de continuer avec lui et
c'est pour ça que je suis là ce soir
vous voulez dire
et pour dire aussi que je ne pourrais
pas le faire seul je vais faire avec une
équipe l'équipe que vous avez vu et je
vais faire avec son public qui est là et
dont j'ai besoin
merci madame france de rendre à un
double hommage à jacques yves cousteau
samedi 28 à 0 heure vingt après
l'édition de la nuit une discussion qui
réunira quelques uns de ses
collaborateurs ou de ceux qui l'ont
côtoyé avant la diffusion de plusieurs
de ses documentaires et le dimanche 29 à
16h45
france 2 vous propose un document inédit
signé couche tôt sur la chine suit de
l'actualité pour des raisons financières
le procès initialement prévu le 6
octobre de maurice papon accusé de
crimes contre l'humanité pourraient être
reportées de deux mois en l'état les
travaux d'aménagement du palais de
justice de bordeaux ne sont pas
intégralement couverts dominique
verdeilhan françois privat le procès de
maurice papon les victimes l'attend
depuis 15 ans elle ne souhaite pas
patienter deux mois de plus c'est le 6
octobre que devait s'ouvrir à bordeaux
les audiences devant juger
l'ex-secrétaire général de la gironde
comme pour le procès de klaus barbie à
lyon une salle préfabriquée devait être
aménagée dans la salle des pas perdus
prévue pour au moins deux mois ce procès
doit accueillir plus de 200 témoins et
victimes et plus de 70 journalistes un
budget de 8 millions de francs étaient
prévus mais les devis s'élève à plus de
15 millions hier soir à bordeaux on
envisageait de reporter le procès à
décembre ou janvier 98 impensable
s'exclament les parties civiles
il n'est pas sûr que les témoins qui ont
été sollicités à l'heure actuelle est
peut-être une chance de vie
il faut tout est limité à l'heure
actuelle et tout est réduit à une
décision opportune
tout sera fait pour maintenir la date du
6 octobre s'engage ce soir le ministère
de la justice mais tout porte à croire
que le procès de maurice papon se
tiendra en fait dans l'actuelle cour
d'assises une salle dans un premier
temps écarté en raison de sa petitesse
une installation vidéo permettrait une
retransmission à l'extérieur ce soir les
conseils des victimes et de maurice
papon sont au moins d'accord sur un
point ils exigent que les audiences se
déroulent dans un climat digne d'un
procès pour crimes contre l'humanité
nouveau drame à la suite de l'opération
anti pédophile un instituteur s'est
pendu mardi à royan l'homme avait été
mis en examen pour recel de cas de
cassettes à caractère pédophile
quatre personnes se sont déjà donné la
mort la ligue des droits de l'homme a
dénoncé une opération trop médiatisé
l'actualité sociale martine aubry veut
des plans sociaux qui tienne la route
selon ses propres termes
le ministre de l'emploi et de la
solidarité a précisé devant l'assemblée
nationale les grands axes de la réforme
sur les licenciements qu'elle prépare
sébastien guibert lionel jospin l'avait
annoncé jeudi dernier ici même à
l'assemblée martine aubry l'a confirmé
aujourd'hui les lois sur les
licenciements économiques et les plans
sociaux vont être revus améliorer le
ministre s'en est pris notamment sans la
citer à l'entreprise peugeot dont la
direction a annoncé au début du mois un
sévère plan social une fois de plus
cette entreprise je dirais considère que
c'est l'état qui doit régler ses
problèmes de restructuration et que moi
une fois de plus je considère que quand
on gagne de l'argent
quand on prend des décisions de
restructuration lorsqu'on est en
monopole dans certaines régions eh bien
on a le devoir de faire un plan social
qui tienne la route c'est-à-dire qui
prévoit la reconversion qui aident les
salariés à trouver des emplois qui
ramène des activités qui se contente pas
de donner des chèques départ et faire
payer le reste par des faits neuf c'est
à dire par l'état les effets ne se sont
des mesures de pré retraite à 56 et 57
ans financé en moyenne à 80 % par l'état
et à 20% par les entreprises concernées
le plan social de peugeot prévoit 2008
116 suppressions d'emplois
dont 1970 fn même chose pour renault
dont le plan social a été annoncé en
mars dernier sur 2764 suppressions
d'emplois 2132 effets ne sont prêts mais
martine aubry n'a pas encore annoncé de
mesures concrètes en matière de plans
sociaux
elle entend dit-elle préparer cette
réforme dans la plus grande concertation
jacques calvet président de psa peugeot
citroën prévoit une baisse de 15,6 pour
cent des immatriculations 1997
l'inflation les prix à la consommation
qui n'avaient pas augmenté en avril
enregistre une hausse de 0,2 pour cent
en mai chiffres insee immigration le
ministre de l'intérieur se prononce pour
une politique généreuse mais ferme
dans une interview à notre confrère le
monde sur les objectifs de la réforme
présentée à l'automne jean pierre
chevènement explique que sa décision
récente de régler le sort de plusieurs
milliers de sans papiers n'a rien à voir
avec la régularisation massive engagé en
81 pour lui les reconduites par charters
sont des gesticulations inutiles
à noter à propos des cultes dont il est
en charge que le ministre de l'intérieur
préconise le financement public des
mosquées pour que l'islam rattrape le
statut des autres religions et soit
ouvert et moderne à l'étranger hong kong
à quatre jours du retour de la colonie
britannique dans le giron chinois
les festivités ont commencé un million
de personnes sont attendues en visite
dans le territoire pendant toute cette
période
une foule enthousiaste a également fait
un triomphe dans la journée de mercredi
au défilé des musiques militaires de sa
gracieuse majesté à l'occasion d'un
dernier concert public
en bref encore à l'étranger au moins 60
villageois ont été massacrés en algérie
dans le centre du pays ces derniers
jours
les autorités accusent classiquement des
islamistes droits de l'homme en egypte
l'excision est à nouveau autorisée dans
les hôpitaux un an après la publication
d'un décret gouvernemental qui
l'interdisait accident sérieux mais qui
page sauf c'est le communiqué officiel
publié à moscou après l'accident qui a
eu lieu dans l'espace entre le vaisseau
de ravitaillement et la station orbitale
russe mir
l'accident a eu lieu au moment de la
manoeuvre d'amarrage jean-claude allanic
les deux russes et l'américain qui sont
à bord de mire l'ont échappé belle
voici la station avant la collision et
voici l'état des panneaux solaires
après le choc les sept tonnes du cargo
de ravitaillement progress les ont
littéralement transpercé provoquant un
début de dépressurisation
la hantise de tous les astronautes c'est
en voulant tester le système déjà
défectueux d'arrimage du cargo progress
que l'accident s'est produit ici pour
éviter le pire
les trois cosmonautes noël que quelques
minutes pour évacuer le module spectre
et fermé le sas de sécurité qui isole du
reste de la station le problème sur le
module qui a été percuté a été identifié
par une fuite légère d'atmosphère mais
qui a donné tant à l'équipage de fermer
la porte
donc on peut dire que parmi tous les
modules qui sont comme des chambres
comme des sales laboratoires y en a un
qui en ce moment est interdit d'accès
mais le reste de la station fonctionne
normalement et l'équipage est sain et
sauf c'est malgré tout le deuxième
incident très grave que koné mire en
l'espace de quelques mois
en février dernier un incendie grave
s'était déjà déclaré à bord
et la question qui se pose maintenant
les russes faute de moyens ne sont ils
pas en train de jouer avec la vie des
cosmonautes fait cette édition merci de
nous avoir suivis dans quelques instants
la météo par sophie davant le dernier
journal à zéro heure 10 par véronique
taveau
demain les éditions où sont présentées à
13h par patrick chêne 20h par bruno
masure et l'édition la nuit vous sera
présentée par philippe lefait excellente
soirée à tous
sur france 2